without I mean Rivers were like the
original meta in like ancient human
ancient civilizations there's the
find it pretty
and how you know you had different sects
of humanity
spread out all over the world and
somehow without them ever interacting
with each other everyone figured out oh
you got to build civilization next to
rivers that's that was that was just
like people just everyone figured out
the same thing you know that was just
the matter it's the only matter
if it can't spread they have no other
choice that's the point though that's
not a matter what's the other matter
that's a survival the death metal
described surviving
there's nothing better gone they didn't
choose to oh funny Rhythm we don't
remember the Mesopotamians because they
started the river matter like that was
just like basic Humanity everyone just
living in the river it's just
interesting that throughout all of human
history no one's ever figured out
another way to be able to like survive
it just like we have now well we have
now but not in like Asian history you
know it's not even that ancient I mean
it's it's pretty ancient the ancient
when do you decide ancient history
starts
Neanderthals
I think it starts during the first
civilizations you know like listening
bro the Neanderthals invented the fire
matters like Minecraft it's like you
ever you want to live near where
everything is that's just how it is yeah
it's not a matter it's just what you do
there's no matter what do you matter
because not everything's a meta it's a
matter no it's not a matter it's a
matter because it's the most effective
tactic available and the other tactic is
uh dying or not having a civilization to
begin with matter implies that one day
there was like a Mesopotamia who was
like I figured it out
check this [ __ ] out boys but there is
walks to a river and then everyone's
like oh my God
I want to Google the definition of
America yeah it's most effective tactic
available no that's that's literally in
in gaming that's literally what it's
called oh so you're deciding the meaning
of the word how am I more how am I more
of a game with a new one
I actually didn't know
I was just like oh it's the one time I
get to be more of a gamer than Connor I
was like oh that's a cool one
it's referring to itself or to the
conventions of its genre no no that's a
different type of meta that's that's
like what are you talking about we're
talking about m dot e dot T dot a yeah
like a game meta would you say that
again m dot e dot T dot a like the
abbreviated form of metal what's the
abbreviation Center what did he just say
most effective tactic available I know
this I've watched enough League video is
to know that this is a thing okay I'm
not making [ __ ] up no I believe [ __ ] you
that must have come after the word
matter was already being used for that
and someone decided let's add a let's
add like a meaning what's the word
called when you add uh each uh letter
has a meaning what's called again
abbreviations
no I'm saying the word meta has it
wouldn't matter existed and was that
before and then that abbreviation was
just tacked on after yeah no that's yeah
obviously yeah but why are you implying
that no no because it says this thing so
it must be no I just I just said the
river meta as in just referring to it as
well I didn't realize you're talking
about the
m.e.e.t.a oh no it literally doesn't
even make sense if I like use the other
meaning it literally doesn't make sense
it doesn't make sense with the gaming
meeting either
yeah it does the most effective tactic
available what's the league meta what's
the league what's the current lead sort
of tactic it's zero tactic
what are you talking about it what's the
current OverWatch matter people say that
all the time you're in the game yeah
that's a survival that's literally
everyone on [ __ ] twitch uses it for
everything now
oh my God
okay to be fair just because people on
Twitter saying it it doesn't mean it
applies to history I'm not saying that
like you're not gonna say like oh man
when when when Caesar was killed he was
real
the smoking matter in the 1930s was wild
dude let me talk about that that was a
peak smoking matter dude everyone was
broken like what are you talking about
that wasn't a minute that wasn't what
I'm saying it's like that's like calling
it the [ __ ] the copium the the Great
Sage depression like that's like like
what are you talking about they conquer
the Chinese
[Music]
the green the great search
like you're adding a word to it like
what the [ __ ] are you talking about it's
a great search I'm just gonna call him
don't tell me that stuff that doesn't
make any [ __ ] sense it doesn't make
any sense but it makes it [ __ ] a
great suit
like The Swinging 60s is just the cat
jams the cat challenge decade
twitch's twitch has rotted my mind
that doesn't discount
it does this it does it's completely
discounts there's a reason why everyone
did it it's not because they all well
I'm sure I'm sure when the Mesopotamians
figured out let's live near a river I'm
sure there's not enough of the
Mesopotamians because they were the ones
that like started it you don't know that
yeah that we do we literally know from
Recess huh tell me Mesopotamia literally
means living near a river I'm just
[ __ ] with you yeah
I'm sure there's a historical term for
her but we don't know the historical
terms so we just allude to that by just
saying River metal yeah we're the same
guys who just started talking about
Disney extreme skin Adventure I don't
think we have any place
like you you're saying this like you
know everyone would have you know
everyone it's obvious it was obvious
well it wasn't obviously had no choice
yeah they died if they they literally
died right it's like saying
no it's not a tactic it's not a tactic
it's like okay why did people not just
use fire immediately why why didn't
humans not just like invent fire
immediately it was because people didn't
know that [ __ ] I find it I just found it
interesting that everyone figured this
out by themselves individually you know
that's I I think that's pretty [ __ ]
interesting I I'm is this human
evolution right
human evolution if it's all a harmonious
at the same same time everyone did the
same thing dude evolution is just a
fancy way of saying the new metal no
it's not
we actually we evolved absolutely we
evolved to create the new metal actually
[Music]
[Applause]
Darwin didn't die for this
this is like we evolved because we found
the new meta
is that like in his notes he was like
well yeah so the sequels discovered the
new meta of having a longer beak yeah no
because because the seagull one day was
just like what if I just had a longer
beak
and then all the other seagulls are like
oh [ __ ] he's figured out the metal we
should follow along otherwise we're
gonna die yeah
I'm not going to entertain this anymore
I'm not gonna I'm there's no point even
why am I even debating this it's stupid
I shouldn't debate this oh my God
ancient history is interesting oh no no
it is it is yeah but it's not a matter
it also it all started from a River's
documentary a river Symphony yeah I need
to see this yeah